tu m'en vais
mais man est mort d'une overdose des
rolling rock voilà qu'on lui donne et il
va acheter de l'héroïne pour sa copine
et sans doute il va l'essayer dans les
toilettes quoi et on le retrouve mort
dans les toilettes avec son paquet à la
main le coeur c'est arrivera et là le
patron du rock and roll circus sam
bernett est vraiment embêté parce que
pouvaient le chanteur des doors mort
dans des toilettes à l'époque c'est la
fermeture totale le scandale est serré
ça et donc ils vont rouler morrison dans
un tapis le sortir par un club voisin
qui donne sur la rue dauphine le chargé
dans une voiture le ramener rubod
treillis dans le marais le monté au
troisième étage et le mettre dans une
baignoire d'eau glacée en se disant au
cas d'overdose c'est un peu le système
du pauvre pour faire le truc là lors
qu'on voit souvent dans les films de
tarantino et donc cela cet effort est
désespérée et morrison reste mort voilà
et là ils appellent agnès varda qui va
maquiller toute cette histoire avec le
médecin de famille c'est agnès qui avait
réglé tout ça est incroyable c'est
madame johanne lemay bien raconté le
couple devait raconter toute cette
histoire et puis après beaucoup de
journalistes lui disait agnès vous
pouvez nous raconter size et j'ai tout
dit à philippe manoeuvre
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux